what do you think like the top five
vegetables should be then well i would
have to say for one dark leafy greens
and you know i think kale can be i
happen to like kale
it's so divisive so divisive yeah but
i'm not recommending that i'm saying
that like i like it i don't really have
you know any any major issue digesting
it but i think arugula is phenomenal
romaine lettuce yeah mixed greens all
great all great and
super nutrient dense because they're
rich in folate and vitamin c but they
provide very few calories which which
increases their nutrient density right
by definition we know that people who
eat a bowl of dark leafy greens every
day have more youthful brains so brains
that perform up to 11 years younger meat
of all kinds including fish i'm sure
right proteins and you've got
fruit
vegetables
what's next are we to wine yet because
if we're not to like chocolate and wine
i just you know
[Music]
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast uh thanks for listening uh today
you're in for a treat max lugavir is on
the show and he shares all of his great
knowledge about food and like he has
this amazing approach to life that i
think is going to be contagious or i
hope so because so balanced and
beautiful um he is a wellness journalist
he has a podcast called the genius life
and he's written two books called genius
foods and genius kitchen so check those
out um man we just covered cool things
we talked about like some of his love
loves and interests outside of food even
um and he's got this famous smoothie and
you've got to hear what's in it because
it's super good for you and keeps your
blood sugar really stable which is kind
of a rarity with smoothies we created a
food pyramid so you've got to listen to
the end to hear the food pyramid because
i think it's epic and i want to
implement it across the board i know
you're gonna also hear like how people
end up getting to develop the food
pyramid and who gets in to do that and
i'm just gonna say it's probably not
fair what they try and tell us to eat
but max has the solution all things
health and wellness
and all things balance and a great way
to approach life and great ways to look
at things like vegan carnivore
dairy all kinds of things that have like
stigma or like there's like what do i do
what do i not do he has some great
answers so
uh thanks for coming by thanks for
listening please hit the subscribe
button and let me know what you think in
the comments
who really likes to listen to their
voice anyway do you ever listen to your
stuff being like oh god it's like nails
down a chalkboard i have to listen to my
voice at one and a half speed like on
podcasts otherwise i'm like oh why do i
talk so slow
which i don't think i talk slow but when
i'm listening back to it you know it's
just like come on get on with it
maybe you process that fast maybe maybe
i do listen to other things at one and a
half speed yeah i typically do i
typically do i think that there's like
yeah our brains are able to process
information faster than our lips are
able to convey
information so
i agree with that i listen to books at
as fast as speed as i can digest it
which usually falls at that one and a
half to
two sometimes interesting interesting do
you actually sing though
actually truth is when i was a kid
i wanted to be a singer
and i took voice lessons when i was
really young
and
the teacher would like touch my stomach
and i thought and he was it just grossed
me out so i quit i stopped after that
summer's lessons i was like i'm not
comfortable with this
old man
sitting at a piano touching me so pretty
cringe yeah so i guess i could have been
a pop star maybe no i don't think i you
know i like to joke i harmonize really
well because when the music's up and i'm
singing people are like wow
you're sound pretty good and then i turn
the music down for myself in the car i
don't know if you've ever done that
before just to
see how you really sound and i turn it
down and i'm like
not so great
interesting
yeah i uh
i don't know i mean i love i actually
sing and i but it's something that like
i i've learned over the years i've
taught myself i've worked really hard to
be able to do it and it's like it's so
gratifying
um and and fun to be able to do
how do you teach yourself
well
i think at a certain point i
realized that
enough people in the world
can sing and can sing well that there's
got to be something teachable about it
there's got to be something that you
know that it's not magic i mean
certainly some people are born with
beautiful tones and they they you know
are practicing since they're like
toddlers
and that certainly wasn't me but
um but i just figured that there had to
be something like that i was able to
learn about about doing it like when i
before i knew before i learned about
singing i thought that people just kind
of like it was just a different way of
talking and some people sounded better
than others you know but you actually
have to i didn't know that you actually
have to use your voice to hit certain
notes like scales on a piano
and once i learned that i had that
revelation which sounds very rudimentary
but um
but i just was like i practiced and i
took a few voice lessons and i just
reped like repetition over and over and
over again and so i'm not like amazing
by any means but i definitely can can do
it and it's like
one of the greatest things like just the
the practice of it it's one of the most
gratifying things i've ever embarked on
wow yeah wow there's so many thoughts
that come to mind like growth mindset
like have you ever read mindset no by
carol dweck i mean i think they they use
like art as an example in the book but
it's it's talking about you know your
ability to either be a fixed mindset
person or growth and with growth you
sort of associate with the process
instead of the outcome
and you also believe that you can learn
things again because you're process
oriented and so it like shows people
drawing a picture that they're told to
draw and then they take like a day class
of
painting or drawing and then it shows
the picture at the end of the day and
it's like infinitely better and so it's
not just that you can't do things or can
it's that you need to apply yourself
like i sucked at racing before i started
right
but then i didn't suck so much and so
you know that's oh gosh that's
interesting you play an instrument with
it too yeah i play guitar i play guitar
yeah
in the corner and i just like
wish i knew how to play guitar but i
don't practice
practice makes perfect
it's like the 10 000 hours i don't know
i mean i'll never be like you know john
mayer on on the axe right but like
i can play well enough to accompany
myself and like and actually perform
like out like sing a song with my guitar
oh my god yeah it's that sounds so fun
it's totally growth mindset which i i
think to me has been a major like life
lesson with
that has bled into other areas of my
life that it's what they say like
whatever you set your mind
too you can you can achieve like it
proved to me that while you can't do
um everything like you can't do
everything right we just don't have that
kind of time or or cognitive capacity we
can do
anything that we set our mind to
provided it's like you know we focus on
the one thing whatever it whatever it
happens to be and so for years i just i
dedicated myself to to practicing music
and learning and um
and yeah and i was like terrible and i
was less terrible over time and then
you know maybe occasionally i sounded
all right and then sort of the delta
between the amount of time that you
sound all right
so the time that you you know spends
sucking sort of shrinks and then
eventually you
you know
yeah you figure it out and i might have
confidence to do it in front of people
yeah yeah yeah it's awesome it's been
like yeah i love it it's um
it's like
my my brain is like a light switch like
i'm i'm passionate about if i'm
passionate about something i'm obsessed
with it
and there's just like yeah i can tell
and so
it's like for me there's like a very
small handful of things that i'm
obsessed with music is one of them
cinema and like movies is another and
then health
so just those three things like i can
talk fluently about those three things
and then i can't really you know
everything we're gonna cover those three
things then today i didn't plan on two
of them but that's okay because i love
talking about things that light people
up and
having that growth mindset with being
able to learn how to sing and play the
guitar and be a musician that it
affected so many other areas of your
life so first i wanted to ask that
because it sounds like there's more
stories
yeah it's like it had like a spillover
effect like what i was able to prove to
myself with music
um it's the same way
you know i'm i'm essentially an auto
didact so like i learn best by myself
and i'm that's not to say that i uh
don't accept expert help when when i
need it um but in general like i'm i'm
just a passionately curious person and
um and i obsess on things and i just i
try and try and try and try
until uh i eventually you know there's
like the the semblance of success
and um
and so that kind of informed my health
journey in many ways like
um
you know i'm i didn't become
uh i'm not an academic i didn't go
through medical school i don't have a
phd in nutrition but
um it's the passion really for health
and nutrition
that is what propelled me and motivated
me and kept me going
to amass and aggregate all the
information that i that i have today you
know that i've written that fills my
books and that fills my podcast and
and and all of that and it's that sort
of entitlement to
information and to insight and to
mastery
that um
that i feel like was applicable in music
and is is also applicable to what i do
with my health
um
yeah it's sort of like malcolm gladwell
in the book outliers talks about this
sort of um
the positive side to entitlement i mean
we tend to think of entitlement as this
bad
personality trait and most of the time
it is right like in in social settings
and social settings entitlement is
pretty bad but um
and in with our relationships right
but i think that there's a form of
entitlement that's
uh
that we can apply to
um to knowledge and to wisdom and to
insight and to
acquiring new skills right
that i think is actually very beneficial
and that's what malcolm gladwell talks
about in outliers basically that like
one of the commonalities among all
seemingly successful people is that they
felt entitled to the success that
they've earned they felt entitled to
whether it was
shake up an industry like for example
what elon musk has done with the
electric car industry or the car
industry in general right because it
didn't really exist before him um or
uh what you did in the world of racing
you know like or
um what i've done in the in the world of
health like i could have easily have
said oh i'm not
you know what's a guy like me with no md
no phd gonna have to offer right in the
in terms of the grander
health conversation but i felt entitled
to to answers and i
um and i felt entitled to to
teach and to share
and um and yeah so that those were i
feel like if i didn't have that early
experience with music i wouldn't have um
yeah my perspective would be
a bit different what is your definition
of entitled then in that context
that's a good question i mean i think it
just means that in a way there's no
um
that nothing's off limits really that uh
that in a way
you are deserving
of
um
of of
what it is that you seek whatever that
happens to be
now when applied in social settings like
you're not deserving of anybody's
anybody else's resources right
or anybody else's time or love or what
have you like you earn your love or the
love that you get from others or the the
resources that others
choose to share with you right
um
and that's a two-way street in the
social setting but
um
we live in an incredible time now where
all of the world's knowledge is
available
to each person at their fingertips 24
hours a day right so that's just it's
out there it's there for the taking
so if you don't feel entitled to take it
nobody's going to hand it to you
right
so i think that that
feeling a sense of like i deserve to
quench my curiosity when it arises
that's something that i think is like
really powerful and i think a positive
application of this
um
otherwise sort of uh the this
concept that can otherwise have a
negative connotation
yeah i like that i like that definition
a lot um all right well movies like okay
first off just name your favorite movie
let's just start there oh god that's so
hard okay name your top three okay um
well i love uh
god off the top of my head i mean it's
like it's like when a musician is like
playing uh playing a show the reason why
they have a set list is because when the
spotlight is like actually on you you
forget all the songs you've ever written
and so it's sort of like similar when
you're put on the spot about like your
favorite like movies or songs but i
guess like i'm a huge fan of v for
vendetta
oh good that was an incredible movie i
love the dialogue in that film
um
and the sort of the philosophical
undertones and the sort of i like i'm
drawn to
more moody
uh themes darker side kind of themes and
movies
dystopias you know portraits of like
of of dystopic
universes and i feel like
vendetta is a great sort of example of
that i love christopher nolan so like
call me too inception might come out my
favorite movie is interstellar is it oh
cool with matthew mcconaughey right yeah
yeah but inception's kind of got almost
like that
it's not super dark but it definitely
i'm thinking of movies that i like and
i'm like
you know there's that sort of
psychological dark side to
why we do what we do and how we
go about our life
you know yeah
yeah i mean i can get a bit nihilistic
at times i
um you know i'm of the belief that like
life there's a lot of suffering that
comes along with life
kind of embedded in our existence i
think
yeah yeah no matter who you are you know
a lot of people like to weaponize this
concept of like privilege today but i
think for no matter who you are
like
life is suffering we what we watch our
parents get older become decrepit and
ultimately pass and i think that's a
really hard thing i mean i experienced
it um
and so
i like
art that kind of explore that explores
those
kind of themes and then
prevents uh prevents like presents a
sort of like
you know an alternate
world
you know
for example
vendetta it's this it's clearly this
like dystopic world where people are
under you know authoritarian control and
v the main character is like almost like
this superhero who
um
fights against the status quo
and uh and that's something that like
i think is really inspiring and um and
you know i can i can kind of relate to
it that's sort of like true fighting
truth to power
um idea like i can relate to it with my
work in health
and so um
yeah i kind of i don't know i just
they those kinds of like themes speak to
me
did you ever watch dexter
you know i never did yeah it seems like
totally right up your alley like it's
about this guy that just freaking
murders everyone but he's doing it for
the right reasons like he's like right
he's like a good murderer
it's funny you bring that up because
actually you reminded me my my other
favorite it's not a movie but it's like
tv
long form tv six feet under is one of my
favorite shows of all time
and i think one of the major reasons why
i didn't watch dexter is because to me
michael c hall
who plays the gay younger fisher brother
in in six feet under i can i never
wanted to see him as anything but that
and so
yeah and he's the star i'd love to just
enter the world i'm just gonna stay in
that world yeah pretty much that world
like it is and then we'll go to a
different world okay yeah because it
betrays the illusion you know like i see
movies almost as a as a form of truth
which they are really and so six feet
under is like a perfect example of that
and so when i
um
when i catch those actors in other
projects and especially if the projects
aren't like
thematically similar or if they're bad
um it kind of like bursts the bubble for
me which makes me is like a little bit
of cognitive cognitive dissonance which
i don't know
yeah
oh i like that okay all right cool
um
so
uh health that's the third bucket
hot hot minute here we i first have to
start off with what the hell is in this
smoothie that everyone loves
this purple smoothie yes
okay so
i launched a smoothie with
earth bar which is where where what
state are you in by the way i don't know
i'm in arizona you're in arizona okay so
you're not far yeah
um
there are earth bars it's like it's like
a smoothie shop all around california
does it have food too i feel like is
there one in laguna
i believe so yeah but anyway so i
launched a smoothie with them it's
called the genius smoothie
and uh it's super tasty i was never much
of a smoothie guy
but um
but i launched the smoothie with them
which is like not overly sweet there's
no bananas in it i feel like most of the
time you go to a you know get a smoothie
it's like all frozen banana just leaves
you in a glycemic coma afterwards so
mine is like primarily blueberries and
um we get a little bit of frozen avocado
which is uh very low glycemic yeah
rich in healthy fats
um
and then some whey protein which is
super high biological value
uh source of essential amino acids and
branched chain amino acids and then
cinnamon a cacao extract that's
yeah it's bought it tastes like an
oatmeal cookie it's really freaking good
and people have been loving it which is
awesome
that's awesome well i would totally
check it with my continuous blood
glucose monitor to
but everyone's different that's the one
thing i found is that um with like
checking your blood sugar definitely
there are some things that just don't
spike it as much but um it's it's a
little individual
yeah but it's a good it's uh that sounds
delicious it sounds like something i
would put like if i were gonna do it i i
mean like a little banana's lovely like
a quarter of a banana even just to like
make it creamy but the avocado does the
job yeah it's creamy
yes you would like it i think and people
that follow me have been who wear cgms
yeah have been posting some i mean i've
seen like two or three people post like
their curves
and it doesn't seem to spike blood sugar
at all amazing yeah it's good
yeah it's a it's like a brain boosting
smoothie that also has great a great
source of protein
good for muscle protein synthesis
and um and yeah it's cool you know like
in la we've got there's the haley bieber
smoothie
over it over at erawan and then there's
like the max luca beer
genius smoothie at earth bar so it's
like it feels kind of cool to be in that
arena you know uh so what are you into
these days like what i mean when it
comes to like health i feel like people
ask me all the time they're like what
are you eating these days like what are
you doing these days people when they're
when i'm traveling and working and they
have to order meals for me or get meals
for whatever it is i'm doing events or
planes or anything they're like
what are you eating um so i feel like
there's always something in the testing
and being tested and run so
like what is that for you right now
yeah i mean you know i
i think i continue to advocate for
um
the
consumption of minimally processed foods
like animals and plants which is like so
controversial online and to me it's like
the least controversial thing ever
um
but you know like people people in the
nutrition space they're very polarized
by their by their diet tribes whatever
those happen to be whether it's like the
plant-based community or the carnivore
community or like the low-carb community
or the keto community
yeah um
[Music]
but uh but yeah i mean i guess like the
things that i'm really enjoying talking
about lately
um
i've been sort of i actually my views on
dairy have changed i don't know where
you were used to stand on dairy but i
used to be like when i first got into
the wellness world there's this dogma
that like dairy is bad it's like you
know it's like oh yeah i didn't eat
dairy for years yeah
and and i get it like a lot of people
are lactose intolerant and um
and you get a lot of pressure from the
plant-based community not to consume
dairy and there's a lot of money from
the plant-based alternative like milks
you know to steer consumers away from
dairy but if you actually look at like
what it is it's an incredibly
nutrient-dense food it's one of the most
nutrient-dense foods um available to
people right and it's very inexpensive
and it's got all these like
micronutrients in it great source of
protein
especially when you look at specific
dairy products like greek yogurt or
um
whey protein which i'm a big fan of
and i'm not sponsored by the dairy
industry it's just that i've sort of i
went and i looked at the research on
dairy and it's really not like it's not
inflammatory like there's like this
people think that like milk is an
intrinsically inflammatory it's not and
so
um i've been enjoying sort of like
talking about that a bit because i think
it's really important especially
when you're in a position
of influence um in the in the nutrition
sphere to share with people where your
views change you know because that's
what science is it's like iterative
and if you're not willing if you're not
willing to check your your beliefs and
your assumptions
um on a regular basis
then you're not
really
that's like not scientific you know
you're just like being dogmatic yeah
exactly
yeah so i have i agree i let's see i
went gluten and dairy free probably like
back in like 2013 and then
probably
2015 paleo and then i stayed like that
for quite a while
um until probably
last year maybe 2021 ish and but now
this sort of raw
dairy market is very intriguing and
when you think about the
um how many
healthy how much healthy bacteria and
how much bioavailable nutrients there
are and it's not stripped with heat and
all these processing uh mechanisms to
clean it
um you're kind of having a live food
versus a dead food
and so i
and then i also would do more of goat
cheese i've always loved goat cheese but
i cut that out even for that time period
so goat cheese and feta because it's
goat and sheep right so it's not really
dairy essentially
um i believe that's well that's what
i've been told um and then raw and then
some raw stuff so raw cream um kefir or
kefir how do you pronounce it
i think it's kefir but kefir sounds more
like legit like you know in its origin
language like i could i would believe
that it's more like target versus target
yeah exactly so we'll go with kefir yeah
um and um butter raw butter
so all the raw stuff and you guys can
get that pretty easy in california
it is pretty easy to find yeah i think i
like sprouts we now have raw dairy and i
i allegedly raw dairy i haven't vetted
this for myself but raw dairy has
it has lactose in it which is the
problematic sugar that people 75 of the
global population has difficulty
digesting but it also
allegedly has lactase in it which is the
enzyme so
what lactose intolerance is is an
ability to produce the lactase enzyme
which breaks down lactose
but apparently in uh
and again this is just like i'm
i haven't vetted this but apparently raw
dairy has lactase in it to make it
you can basically like easily digest it
even if you're lactose intolerant so
nature made it perfect yeah
yeah i mean so i'm a big fan of of like
minimally processed foods and like
animal products i think really really
valuable um i've been sort of batting
heads with uh
you know a lot of the science coming out
lately
is um
really i mean
seemingly funded by the food industry
and and i think with the intent of
leading consumers
astray i don't know if that's the intent
but it certainly seems that way
and um
and you know there's this push i think
towards
like highly processed ultra-processed
foods these days um from our most
trusted academic institutions you know
and i think it's a big problem i mean
today 60 of of people consume like the
calories that most people consume are by
and large from these like ultra
processed foods these are the foods that
line our supermarket aisles they're
shelf-stable
they're not real they're like not even
real food exactly and they're really the
foundation of the epidemic of modern
chronic disease which includes obesity
and um and and you'd be surprised how
much like
dissuading
consumers from those kinds of foods you
actually get like pushback from
from like the industry you know and it's
just like really maddening that's their
cognitive dissonance you have cognitive
dissonance around seeing a character in
a movie playing a different role but
these people are like don't mess with my
pop-tarts
those are my life yeah
and they're all i mean i think they're
all
chills for the for the food industry at
this point it's really sad
um and i and so i understand why why so
many consumers are confused when it
comes to like what it means to eat
healthily these days
um
so yeah it's cheaper too i mean you look
at a lot of stuff i mean you know things
that take giant
multi-million dollar billion dollar
industries with
factories and all these you know trucks
and everything it takes to
get the product to market and then it's
a dollar nineteen and then
you see something else that's pulled out
of the dirt and put on a shelf and it's
5.99 and so it's
it seems counterintuitive like why do
you think
why do you think that there's such a
difficulty for people to transition
to
recognizing how
bad some things are for you
well i think a lot of it does come from
the from the food industry i mean you
you walk through like your average
supermarket
and there's some ridiculous percentage i
forget exactly what it is but by and
large super the supermarkets are filled
these days with these kinds of foods
right and these are the foods that
make health claims
so like
you see the red heart healthy logo on
the canola oil right but you don't
typically see it on extra virgin olive
oil
right or a beet you know it's not like
there's a sticker that says like good
for your heart yeah exactly on beets or
on or on broccoli or even on even on
eggs right like eggs are one of nature's
perfect foods it's like a duh i think
the vegeta like the natural stuff is
just says duh
yeah
so that's why i think i think consumers
are and also it's like these foods are
easy they're always at arm's reach
they're high margins so they're heavily
promoted by the food industry
they tend to be what food scientists
refer to as hyper palatable so they have
this quality that makes them
um
impossibly delicious you know i think
like
everybody's had that experience of like
opening a pint of ice cream and
intending to have like a spoonful or
even a serving size and end up eating
the whole pint right
like you're not weird if that's happened
to you you're human you're a victim of
marketing of also food science because
they make that stuff
so that there's like some perfect ratio
right there's some perfect ratios of
sort of sweet and salty crunchy creamy
intersection point between the perfect
amount of certain things that keep you
wanting more hmm
yeah i think i think i've heard it
referred to as the dorito effect oh yeah
you know but i mean it's it's not just
doritos you can
run a little thought experiment for
yourself if you were to think of like a
baked potato like you probably wouldn't
be
prone to over consuming a plain baked
potato like you probably wouldn't you'd
you know maybe have like a spoonful and
you'd be like i've had enough of that
but the minute you add
butter to it right and not just any
butter but salted butter so you're
adding fat and salt right to the starch
suddenly that potato becomes
hyper palatable becomes like this insane
thing so it's not it's not even
necessarily something that is like uh
exclusive to
food manufacturers it's just that the
human tongue knows when it's when it's
attained a calorie-dense
food which for the vast majority of our
of our evolution before we had
food security right we were food
insecure and so to the the ability to be
able to recognize a calorie dense source
of food was actually a life-saving trait
so that was selected for
in the human genome
so if you eat food dense if you eat
calorically dense food you're just smart
yeah pretty much
or a survivor at the very least
right but that sets up like a really
simple operating system that's why we
store fat right i mean early on the
those of us who were able to store the
most fat the the most easily would be
the ones that were
most likely would be most likely to
survive the winter right periods of food
scarcity
ah this brings up an interesting topic
of
what makes us store fat because when you
said that it made me start thinking
about fasting and how
in ancient and older times where there
was less readily available cans of
campbell soup on the shelf you know
there were periods of time that you'd
fast and periods of times that you'd
feast and so
what is it that makes us store fat then
if back in those days it seemed like
there was far more clean foods and if
you needed to make it through the winter
what made us put the fat on so that we
could survive
yeah that's a good question i think i
mean there are
a few variables at play i mean first and
foremost it's you know to store fat
you're essentially consuming more
calories than you're burning every day
that's like that's like level one of the
of i think
you know the phenomena is that energy
balance like if you're if you're if
you're consuming more calories in your
burning every day but the issue is that
that when when people take that sort of
mathematical
maxim as as
sort of advice that's when i think
people get led astray because
in the calories in calories out equation
calories out
meaning the amount of calories that you
burn every single day right whether it's
via exercise or just navigating the
world
that's highly influenced by myriad
variables including hormones including
stress
um
including your body composition for
example
so
you know to make everything about
calories i think does a disservice to
people who are really struggling with
their weight i think primarily it's
our
unyielding proximity to these
hyperpalatable calorie dense
foods that are minimally so
along with their caloric density they're
min they tend to be minimally satiating
and humans
don't we we don't like we're not good at
moderating our hunger especially when
all we do are eat these kinds of foods
and so the i think what's really
important for people to know is are sort
of like the factors that make a food
satiating because we all want to eat to
that feeling of fullness right we're not
designed to
stop eating
at 50 percent of the way you know to
satiety
right
and ultra processed foods they tend to
be not satiating because they are
usually dehydrated because water impedes
a food's shelf stability so
manufacturers remove the water from a
food which is water is inherently
satiating in and of itself
yeah exactly
right
yeah as you take another step by the
size of my head it's great i mean like
if you think about if you think about
first of all
water you could go a month or two
without eating any food but two or three
days without water
you're in deep in deep trouble right so
when water ceased to be available for
one of our hunter-gatherer ancestors
where would the next best place to find
water be it would be food right fruits
and vegetables we all know great source
of water but even animal products great
source of water right i mean an organism
is 72 73 something like that percent
water kind of like us
yeah and so if you're if you're
hungry i mean it could just be that
you're dehydrated right yeah but also we
know that foods that are hydrating tend
to be more satiating than foods that are
dehydrated where does salt fall into
that because like i have a little bit of
like element in here and
i love it um a little bit of trace
minerals and um
i love almond too it's actually so
delicious and it's there's some there's
a bunch of obviously options but i do
like element watermelon's my favorite um
anyway
so what is it so where does it fall into
the
potentiality of i actually really want
to talk about water for a second
um why would salt make sodium and
potassium or sodium magnesium potassium
where does that sort of trio fall in
making you feel better
well yeah that's a good question so
those are all electrolytes and when you
sweat for one you lose electrolytes in
your sweat and sodium is the one that
you lose the most of
sodium is an incredibly important
vital nutrient and in fact you know we
have a lot of colloquial sayings that
kind of hint at just how valuable sodium
and salt specifically have been
throughout history like saying that
somebody is worth their salt right
that's how valuable so the word salary
right actually it's thought the word
salary derives from cell which is salt
thought it was celery yeah celery
[Laughter]
really it derives from salt
yeah that's cool i didn't know that
yeah it was a very solid to the earth
salt of the earth yeah it was used i
believe it was used as a currency in
certain parts of the world um which all
that is to say that salt was a very
valuable i mean extremely valuable
nutrient you need
it's a macro mineral you need a
relatively high amount of sodium every
day to sustain good health to contrast
to like a trace mineral like you only
need a couple of milligrams a day of
zinc
to sustain health right like if you're
eating the standard american diet you're
getting enough sodium but that's because
these products tend to be loaded with
sodium to
improve their flavor profiles but if
you're eating
if you're on the path to good health
which i'm assuming many of your
listeners
are you know because it's something that
that you're into
then you actually have to become
cognizant of like where you're getting
your sodium like i try to eat minimal
packaged processed foods on a daily
basis and like it could be like hours
sometimes if i haven't salted my food i
likely haven't gotten much sodium
i've like the le the
i mean i
i mean i eat very well um
but like i've found that
i need more and especially if i'm doing
um
a little phase of low carb or any level
of fasting it really seems like
salt is so necessary like
today's one of those days and you just i
just feel like if i don't have some
sodium added to my water i just i low
i'm low energy
yeah i feel that way too and as yeah as
you mentioned when you're low carb
just on 24 hours of initiating a low
carb diet your first 24 hours the amount
of insulin secreted by your pancreas is
cut in half and insulin holds on to
causes your body to hold on to sodium
and so what happens is when you cut your
your insulin levels
um which you know is considered
generally a positive thing you lose
sodium
so
imagine being on a lower carbohydrate
carbohydrate diet you're in one of these
parts of the world like you are where
it's very dry right and then you throw
sweating on top of that exercise which
we know is beneficial
maybe you know maybe you're sitting in a
sauna suddenly you're like i will in a
little bit yeah that's booked today too
amazing a hoe cat have you ever heard of
hoe cat no it's like this spaceship
thing you sit in with your head sticking
out and it um
it it's uh like a co2 oxygen chamber so
like you don't shower afterwards because
you want it to sit on your skin and
there's
microcurrent as well so you hold on to
two wands and you put your feet on the
others and you have microcurrent flowing
through your body
with a ton of heat
sick wow yeah it's
yeah so yes exactly so i'm sweating i've
worked out um it's hot in arizona it's
um
low to no carb uh and like an 18 hour
fasting window so like hell yeah i need
my salt yeah you need your salt exactly
it's super super super important you
know and i think it's important for
people to know
um that 11 of the sodium that your
average person ingests comes from their
salt shakers and the recipes that the
food that they that they cook for
themselves at home the vast majority
comes from restaurant food and ultra
processed
food products like shelf-stable
preserved foods
number one shake it on my food more then
yeah it's it's very valuable and what
was that you're just gonna say another
one the number one source of dietary
sodium in the american diet it's not
processed meat it's not canned foods
it's bread and rolls
commercial bread and rolls so if you
if you cut out those kinds of foods for
the most part or you eat them in
moderation which you know somebody like
me like you probably does
um then you're cutting you're exiting
out like a huge sodium contributor from
from your diet so it is it's crucially
important if you don't sort of like
treat or have good water
and have some sort of mineralization to
it or something like a
electrolyte in it
is there some is there sort of like
almost like anti-water like it actually
dehydrates you in any way and i'm asking
because
like a lot a week or two ago i was
drinking water and um i was putting a
ton of more sodium and i was in a longer
fasting window and i kept drinking more
water and i was so thirsty but when i
drink regular water
i'm just without anything in it it just
seems like i don't really want that much
of it so
it it made me thirsty and not only does
it taste better of course there's that
element to it but element but um
but also it just i was thirsty for more
so is that the sodium telling me to
drink more
because it wants to pull more water in
or is there an actual
something else happening i was really
confused yeah well we know that minerals
like these electrolytes definitely do
enhance water uptake
and also carbohydrates do as well like
sugar can
but you know we tend to over consume
sugar these days so i'm not recommending
that people go and put sugar in their
water but um there was a study that
found that compared the hydrating
effects of water
milk uh sodas and things like that and
what they found was that like milk was
that like certain certain fluids were
more hydrating than water itself like
milk probably because of the sugar that
is contained in milk
um
so i'm not saying that you need to can
go and consume sugar because we we all
tend to over consume that anyway but
yeah it's it's definitely true that um
you know your water
will more easily be absorbed absorbed
when you
consume it concurrently with with
minerals but that being said i mean it's
not a major concern shouldn't be a major
concern for most people because you end
up like if you're drinking
say you drink water out of a reverse
osmosis purifier which has nothing in it
right like no minerals and you can drink
it with food like your food has minerals
in it that are gonna increase that are
gonna facilitate
you know that water absorption so it's
not something that i would necessarily
worry about yeah okay
um we were i touched on fasting is that
something you do do you are you over it
they took there's like a few different
contexts in which fasting is sort of
hailed and i think that
in general it's a it's a useful it can
be a useful tool for people it's not
magic it's you don't have to do it for
weight loss
but uh when looking at the research on
what's called early time restricted
feeding i think that there are some
potential metabolic benefits to come
with eating an earlier dinner
and and not eating too late you know
into the evening for one um because
we're diurnal creatures and so our
metabolisms are most pr are primed to be
at their at its most fired up
during the daytime hours so we're most
insulin sensitive during the day
um our metabolisms are higher right and
we have these clocks they're called
peripheral clocks all around our bodies
that are influenced by
by when we eat right
and so
there's this thinking that eating too
late at night can send can sort of cause
asynchrony in these clocks and it can
lead to
impaired glucose regulation
heightened blood pressure which is not
good
um
and so i don't have like a hard and fast
rule about fasting but i do think it's
generally better to eat earlier an
earlier dinner um by like seven eight pm
and and then to not eat
to not really eat um after that the
other thing the other thing about
fasting that makes it a really powerful
tool
to
improve weight it's not more beneficial
from a weight loss standpoint as just
regular old calorie restriction
but if you think about the kinds of
foods that most people eat
um in front of their tvs at night like
after dinner like after dinner snacks
after dinner snacks tend to be
carbs and fat they tend not to be
protein they tend to yeah nobody's
snacking on like you know filet strips
chunk of fillet exactly so
if you
if you adopt like an intermittent
fasting
um protocol for yourself right
and you skim off those three to 400
discretionary discretionary calories of
like
what you would normally eat while
watching your favorite like netflix show
chances are that's junk food right
totally right so like i think it can be
really useful um just sort of as a
general guide rail guy you know sort of
guard rail to have in place
to uh skim off those like discretionary
calories that tend to come from junk
food
yeah yeah good point totally i've been i
mean my preference totally i love to eat
dinner early it's uh
it's so much easier some people are
hungry in the morning some people are
hungry at night though that's the thing
too there's some people that wake up and
they
can't eat you know and so
they're just like i don't even feel good
if i eat or i can't go work out if i eat
and i was always quite the opposite so i
suppose it's easier for me but but just
knowing that and and even just working
on the circadian clock right just you
know obviously it's a little different
in the summer but it's easier to do in
the winter when it's dark by five right
so yeah
following that
eating when it's super dark out tends
not to feel very good for me i think at
the end of the day like personal
preference really does reign supreme
that's one of the things that that the
research seems to show over and over
again that really like
you can
it's like splitting hairs to some degree
like if you're if you
want to eat breakfast then by all means
eat breakfast if you don't like eating
breakfast breakfast you don't have to
eat breakfast you're told by the food
industry that breakfast is the most
important meal of the day but i think
that's really just a was meant just to
sell cereal i shared recently on social
media
that the um there was a paper that came
out that looked at the conflicts of
interests among people
who were invited to contribute to the
2020
dietary guidelines for americans paper
you know every five years
the experts get together right yeah but
yeah like the food pyramid the usda mi
plate every five years so that in 2020
95 of the committee members
had conflicts of interest with pharma
with the food industry yeah
getting that bag right but like what who
suffers from that certainly not them
it's like the american people who just
continue to get more and more confused
right being steered more and more away
from ancestral foods like beef eggs fish
things like that right or liver liver
organ meats yeah and towards these these
high margin
low protein ultra processed equivalents
of like human pet food essentially
that's what the standard american diet
really is now comprised of
primarily and it's and i think it's a
it's a huge problem so
the nutrition science to me it's like
obviously there's a lot of like really
important work that's being done so i
don't want to undermine it completely
but in many ways it is a house of cards
and um and so i've just been very sad
yeah i've been very
disillusioned by the whole
um the whole endeavor and i think it's
it's really sad messed up and so that's
why i just continue to do what i do
putting out the best information that i
can
in hopes of steering people in a
different direction what would max's
food pyramid look like
ooh that's a good question
i think that at the um at the base i
would definitely put high protein foods
i would put like i mean primarily animal
products but then i would also put like
the higher protein plant
foods for people who are
so is there a split
in the middle yeah but i mean
but most of it it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be in the middle because
we know that animal protein is
the highest quality protein that exists
in nature
right you like high fat animal protein
too like would you are you like a firm
believer in kind of like beef
or do you think chicken turkey pork
that's a great question i'm very pro
beef but i do think that it probably
makes sense
um also from an ancestral standpoint to
opt for like leaner cuts and the reason
why i say that
is because when you feed a cow it's
biologically appropriate diet of grass
it ends up being leaner right so that
that that right there tells is a data
point that i use to
to
make make some
degree of determination about the
relative uh
fat to protein ratio perhaps that we're
that we're meant to be ingesting it also
has a lower proportion of saturated fat
uh a grass-fed cow and then if you look
at wild game
wild game is incredibly lean right it's
true venison
all incredibly lean cows are made by
people there's no water that's why
there's grass-fed grass finish there's
like
grass-fed carrot finished
i think i've heard one that was
grass-fed pineapple finished oh wow
i've had the carrot one that's it's
pretty good tasty
of course yeah it's very tender yeah wow
interesting yeah i mean like cows are
cows are domesticated animals like we we
created the cow from i believe the
ancestral cow was like a bison or
something like that right it's not
and they're leaner so
so to me like especially when you know
people's diets you know
like my diet's not perfect right like i
do indulge now and then in in
like comfort foods yolo foods and so i
think uh
you know i think that animal fat is like
is like great and beneficial to a point
but ultimately what i'm trying to do
with my choices is to prioritize protein
okay so is that the full bottom then i
would say that's the bottom yeah and
then and then one layer up would be
fibrous veggies like like
um
like
yeah i'm a fan i mean
don't tell the carnivores but i think
that christopher's vegetables are great
oh i wanna talk about the carnivore
situation yeah and plants i've
i was i paul saladino came and um i met
him through interviewing him and then he
came here and brought all of his like oh
man cleary and honey and
i made him wagyu beef and
yeah all kinds of fatty deliciousness um
but anyway they totally would be like
get that [ __ ] out of here you know look
at my fridge and be like why is there
spinach in your fridge
yeah i think um
i think that they're very they can be
very dogmatic and he's smart he's a
friend like you know i respect his point
of view but
um just because like vegetables certain
vegetables don't work for certain people
doesn't mean that we have to throw the
baby out with the bath water like
you know i like certain vegetables and i
have no problem digesting them and
right they're great for me right so i
think that the that
the sort of one size fits all like just
eat more vegetables that's not good
advice either because people like
you know some people
have impaired gut function right
they have impaired microbiomes so like
you really do have to figure out what's
going to work best for you so what is
the what is what do you use as the
mechanism to decide what you should and
shouldn't eat when it comes to
vegetables then
i think really it should be
it's subjective it should be about how
you feel you know it should be like
digestion bloating yeah
yeah stuff like that like that's not fun
right nobody wants to right like if you
and if you dramatically
increase your fiber consumption from one
day to the next you are going to feel
you know super bloated and feel you know
uncomfortable and that's probably
because you just haven't yet cultivated
the
the
like the microbiome right like the bowel
flora to contend with that sudden
onslaught of fiber
but um people who are cons who are
consistently on high fiber diets and i'm
not saying that everybody listening to
this should go out and adopt a high
fiber diet but
it's true that people that are on high
fiber diets consistently like they don't
have those same kinds of symptoms like
they adapt because they develop the the
gut flora to contend with that that
fiber at the end of the day though fiber
is not an essential nutrient so i don't
i don't tend to push fiber more than i
think uh a reasonable amount to support
gut health it's not essential huh
if you like i would think of fiber and
you think of regularity and so how
do you stay regular if you don't have
fiber in your diet
what are other
triggers that keep things regular
i don't think you need fiber i mean uh
you know at this point i've uh
i've got some pretty close friends that
do the carnivore diet and when when i
ask them about their you know their
bathroom habits they're like it's fine
in fact in fact many of them have had uh
like ibs see i think that that's
actually i think that i think
potentially for people with with gut
problems it can be a great elimination
diet
to adopt super healing at least
temporarily because a lot of these like
you know animal products
anybody who's ever had like a
colonoscopy or any kind of like you know
bowel uh procedure performed
that you what you what you're typically
recommended is to is to go on a low
residue diet for at least a few days
before the procedure and low residue
foods are foods like
beef right
eggs white rice these are the the foods
that are easily broken down and absorbed
primarily and high up in the small
intestine right when people have gut
problems
like i think it's important for people
to like
every once in a while like check out
their stool right and it's it's often
the undigested
food particles it's not from animal like
foods right it's like plants that their
bodies didn't
properly break down right so i think for
people with gut problems it can be
potentially very useful to
do a do an elimination diet and get rid
of plants for at least a time being for
at least a time to allow their guts to
heal
and then to bring those foods back
eventually over time one by one you know
to see what what works for you and what
doesn't what do you think like the top
five vegetables should be then to be in
that sort of
next tier up yeah well your opinion
because it's different for everybody i
get it but like from nutritional
standpoints for
micronutrients
um
vitamins minerals all that good stuff
what do you think the the five
big ones are
well i would have to say for one dark
leafy greens and you know i think kale
can be i happen to like kale
it's so divisive so divisive yeah but
i'm not recommending that i'm saying
that like i like it i don't really have
you know any any major issue digesting
it but dave asprey is just going to burn
you on this one i think arugula is
phenomenal
romaine lettuce yeah mixed greens all
great all great and
super nutrient dense because they're
rich in folate and vitamin c but they
provide very few calories which which
increases their nutrient density right
by definition
and um
and we you know we know that people who
eat a bowl of dark leafy greens every
day have more youthful brains so brains
that perform up to 11 years younger
yeah about a bowl a serving and a third
i believe of dark leafy greens
every day um
that's becoming more and more important
for people like us yeah
and
yeah super and again a very nutrient
dense food and so like whatever your
favorite dark leafy green is but
yeah iceberg lettuce doesn't count no
totally not it's just water yeah so dark
leafy greens that's one
well i would put
i would probably put like fruit there as
well like in that fruit goes in the
vegetable category okay yeah like in
this i mean we i guess we could divide
that you know like we'll fruit fruits
and vegetables like berries and avocados
i think are
olives berries berries avocados and
olives are amazing fruits
very like good data on them also cow
cacao is also a fruit
that's true yeah
so other than leafy greens you're like
screw you carrots
screw you
nightshades
um
carrots are great
yeah i mean vegeta i think i love onions
don't just let me know williams
mushrooms mushrooms are good alliums are
great what are alliums
so garlic leeks onions shallots those
are all alliums great source of
prebiotic fiber
yeah that's why i get leeks i didn't
know why though i just heard it and i
was like ooh get leaks it's a prebiotic
leeks are bombs jicama
jicam is great i love jicama
um
i happen to love fennel you know it's
like
fennel yeah see you
i love love love fennel i like
arugula
i love it raw yeah i don't cook it i
it's always raw arugula
and fennel and um radicchio
and
um those are like the base ingredients
yeah so freaking good like i'm i'm
obsessed see i think that a lot of these
carnivores they grew up with like
parents that just didn't know how to
cook vegetables properly you know so
they were the kids that grew up on they
had like their whatever their diet was
at 12 years old you know they've just
stuck with
and they learned at a certain point that
hot dogs weren't good for them but in
general it's like
you know they're grossed out by the idea
of eating vegetables but i grew up my
mom you know my mom was largely
vegetarian
and um
knew how to season vegetables properly
would put a ton of salt and garlic
on them and so i grew up really enjoying
veggies yeah i agree it's the
preparation of them and like the
argument on that side would be like
would you eat it if it didn't have
anything on it you know and i'm like
kind of
kind of
um okay so we've got like
meat of all kinds including fish i'm
sure
yeah right proteins and you've got fruit
vegetables
what's next are we to wine yet because
if we're not to like chocolate and wine
i just you know
chocolate we could put chocolate on on
the third tier i would put um
i'd put like extra virgin olive oil
maybe on the third tier as well it's not
it's not a nutrient-dense food but i
think it is a functional food in many
ways it's a great source of healthy fats
um
what do you what do you think about mct
oil and sort of the the
brain
you know keto ketosis and brain
activation with mct oil you think that
falls gets any kind of ranking
um i wouldn't say that people most
people need to be consuming it on a
regular basis because it does
convert to ketones
um
after we ingest it and then there is
sort of that ketone push to the brain
post ingestion like it it's you know
those those ketones are pushed into the
brain
but um
but i think it's more useful to make
your own ketones
which somebody you don't have to be on a
ketogenic diet
to do that you know somebody on a
moderate carb diet who's active
will generally like when they wake up in
the morning or after a vigorous bout of
exercise dip into mild ketosis so for me
ingesting mct oil it's all that those
fat calories are only going to displace
the calories that you would otherwise be
um
liquidating from your own fat stores
so for me it's not it's sort of like
empty calories
essentially i do think that for people
with neurodegenerative conditions like
alzheimer's disease
there is a
a potentially useful application there
there's actually a an fda approved
medical food called axona which is based
on medium chain triglycerides because
what happens in the brain of somebody
with alzheimer's disease
they have an impaired ability to
generate atp from glucose okay and so
there's this idea that ketones can sort
of keep the live lights on so to speak
oh it's like fat burning versus sugar
burning so like for energy
yeah exactly and so
um it's possible
that mcts could be useful in that
setting and i think there is a little
bit of data to suggest that it can help
you know like with functional capacity
for those patients but for your average
for your average person it's not
something that i typically recommend
okay
so what's that third tier then just
olive oil and um chocolate yeah let's
put chocolate polyphenols it's the
polyphenol sort of
yeah level to the pyramid coffee coffee
polyphenols right yeah
wine
wine i would put at the top because wine
is like one of these things that i enjoy
i enjoy a good you know glass of wine as
much as the next person and i think that
there was this thinking for a while that
moderate drinking was actually good for
you but i think that that that newer
data has kind of overturned that
thinking and and
i think i'm sorry it's just it broke up
i couldn't hear you i just it's a
so on to the next um i'm just kidding
damn it really like i make wine so i
really want you to say wine do you
consumed on a right yeah i have two
different wines actually i have a napa
valley wine huh i want some yeah you
want some i will send you some do you
have any particular fit i make cab sav
blanc rose and then i also have a french
rose that's made in provence
that's amazing
wow
that's huge holy cow
oh i think wine look i think one's great
i drank it occasionally but um do you
like red
yeah red red is okay well my state
wine's organic as well so this idea of
perfection is is a an impossible yeah
ideal right yeah and wine is like one of
these things that humans you know for
millennia have consumed and you know i
think there's like
um
there are
non-trivial
perhaps non-nutritional benefits
associated with wine it's a great thing
to share with friends it's a social
lubricant it's like
you know it's a de-stressor
and
and all those are our meaningful
potentially meaningful benefits and so
i'm not you know like i'm not anti-wine
i definitely enjoy it but i think it's
like if you can if you can drink
healthily like if you can do it with
like organic
lower sugar
all that stuff you know don't let it
sugar tends to mean lower alcohol like
there's a balancing act with wine and so
when it's lower sugar tends to be lower
alcohol and there's also something
called residual sugar
and so that's kind of what we're talking
about and with lots of wines high
quality wines there's no residual sugar
just an alcohol calorie really and so
the pro the the negative effects tend to
be just hangovers
from too much alcohol from too much
alcohol yeah yeah yeah and like it's 15
and a half percent instead of 12 and a
half percent so you're drunker right how
do you prevent a hangover i mean you
must know like
better more than the rest of us if
you're you know
actually one of the best tricks is to
take activated charcoal before you go to
bed interesting
yeah
and then if you get in the real weeds
the next day um you need to have
always have zofran on hand
what's that it's uh anti-nausea medicine
um it's usually i mean something
prescribed for like cancer patients or
you know sometimes like i had some i had
nad treatments done and so they'll give
me some zofran to start and then do the
nad because it makes you feel like [ __ ]
um so it can kind of kills the
the
the neurotransmitter from your stomach
to your head so you don't know you're
sick
so yeah it's so if you're really in the
weeds you just need to have zofran it's
like the adult
it's the adult tip for life like always
have some zofran wow um but yeah a
charcoal activated charcoal at night two
or three of those at night before you go
to bed if you've been drinking sometimes
i mean even if you've only had two
drinks let's say sometimes that can
still create a little bit of like a
haziness in the morning where you're
like i know i drank you can wake up in
the morning after taking a couple
activated charcoal and feel like
you didn't drink at all amazing i'm
gonna do that
yeah i mean i don't drink that often but
i definitely like couple times a month
have you know
red wine or tequila yeah and uh and
that's that's really good to know i love
tequila too
yeah
it's uh
tequila is low in what are called
congeners which are like you know
essentially these like
the components of
uh spirits like colored spirits that
that can induce
hangover potentially but yeah i think
the biggest needle mover for me is just
to make sure that like i enjoy the buzz
and i'm sober by the time i go to sleep
so yeah that the alcohol doesn't affect
my sleep which means yeah it totally
negatively does
well it'll totally affect your heart
rate very your hrv well even your
recovery if you drank too close to
bedtime will be compromised even if it's
just one but an odd test that was that i
not i didn't do it on purpose but by
nature of just wearing the cgm monitor
and then also
going through life is like i was on a
trip and so some nights we'd be drinking
wine and
my blood sugar was way lower in the
morning when i drank and so there's
probably like you said it's a little bit
of a social lubricant it's a relaxer and
so i wonder
me being someone that has a hard time
you know going in a parasympathetic and
relaxing i wonder if there's just that
sort of psychological
down regulation that happens with the
relaxing from it which is why it's it
has its place
yeah i definitely think so
okay so that's the third tier so it's
all liquids
what's the what's the top what's the top
that is like splurges that aren't stupid
like we're not talking about like you
know going to the cheesecake factory and
killing it or having like you know an
entire like a stuffed crust pizza from
pizza hut like we're not talking about
that i mean you can do those things in
moderation in your life on a super macro
level but like we're talking about like
your little like splurges that happen
once you know a couple times a week yeah
i would say yeah that would that would
be like those would be like the yolo
foods and for me like i love pizza you
know but even when i eat pizza i try to
eat like i try to do it like a little
bit healthier like maybe i'll get it on
like a cauliflower crust if i know a
good place that does that well
um and i'll just go to town on that you
know and i don't like restrict myself so
yeah you know if i want pizza and then
that's like my yolo food for the week or
whatever like
i'll eat as much as i want
um or if it's like gluten free like
grain free like cookies or doughnuts or
whatever you know like i feel like
you can have your cake and eat it too so
to speak it's just like
most people eat those foods not
sort of
knowing the
downstream results you know that they're
gonna feel like crap afterwards um or
that they're not gonna be able to
moderate their consumption of them
um there's no there's no semblance of
like balance i think for most people you
know also they eat them all the time
those kinds of foods like all the time
for me
it's like a once a week thing or once
every other week you know where i'll
have like
yeah you know i'll have like what's
called what i what i refer to as like a
planned indulgence you know like i'll
have like a pizza night with like my
friends or my brothers you know i'll
invite them over and we know that it's
gonna be like a no holds barred like
you know we're just gonna like gorge
ourselves on pizza i think that's that's
like totally fine to do right because
it's informed consent most people don't
have that with the foods that they're
eating they don't know why they
why they over consume certain foods they
don't know the behavioral effects of
these kinds of like hyperpalatable foods
um
so but for me like as long as i
yeah i
like i think you can you can definitely
like integrate them and have them as
part of your diet and whether and if
even if they're not good necessarily for
the body they're good for the soul and i
think that's an important part
balance you know yeah and i think too
there's so much sort of research behind
having those
caloric influx days where you're not
always in this you're not always in a
calorie deficit or you're not always at
a certain sort of maintaining level
there are these sort of dips and valleys
and how it can definitely it can help
your metabolism too and it can help your
base metabolic rate stay a little higher
when you have those days they're a
little bit like okay i eat some things
that make me feel better but i'm still
kind of like overdoing it
yeah for a while in in the world of
bodybuilding there was this idea of like
the leptin refeed
like it like a re like a deliberate
refeed like when you're in a when you're
in a chronic state of a caloric deficit
you know to get for example to lose fat
um
it can over time it can slow your
metabolism as your body gets more
efficient with calorie burning because
it your body doesn't want to waste away
right like your body your body realizes
that it's got to get more efficient with
calories otherwise like it's going to
start you're going to starve to death
and so your metabolism tends to slow
over time and so the idea behind these
leptin refeeds was basically that like
eating foods that were very calorically
dense and and high particularly in
carbohydrates would cause an increase
like a spike in the hormone leptin which
is sort of thought to be like a
metabolic master regulator that's why in
doing that you can sort of cause your
metabolism to
you know go back up to what it was
before
the
the the dieting essentially brought it
down got it so the idea would be that
you can raise the level
hot quicker than it drops so you kind of
keep this ratchet machine up where you
like
have caloric deficit for an ex more of a
longer period of time then you have this
one little spike of a caloric influx
where you had a lot more and so it can
come up more yeah i haven't i haven't
like looked it's been a while since i've
looked into the into the science and the
thinking around that but um but yeah i
know that that people who are like you
know
physique competitors these days like
they'll i i think maybe the knit the
term that people are using now is like
reverse dieting
um
yeah but i mean i'm you know that's uh
that's a little bit out of my wheelhouse
but in general yeah it's like it's
thought that like you know getting off
the diet for a day or two and then and
bringing those kind of foods back will
then you know kind of
work to stoke the metabolic yeah so to
speak all right well top of the pyramid
stoke the flame yeah um
okay are there some things to kind of
wrap things up are there some things
that you used to
consume or do even i mean i would
imagine to some degree
that being interested in health and
wellness that it goes beyond just food
and it can get into other modalities and
different things so are there some so
feel free to include them or not um
are there things that you used to do
that you're like i can't freaking
believe i used to do that like seriously
and are there things now that you feel
like
i'm obsessed with this i don't know how
i'll ever not do this anymore because i
mean those things that you did back then
or at least i'm speaking for myself i
should i should put this first person
there's stuff that i used to do that i
thought oh man this is the best thing i
can possibly do for myself bring on the
soy nuts right yeah and then i thought
you know i'll never be different than
that and then all of a sudden you learn
and so i'm curious what the things what
those things of the past are and what
the things are right now that you're
obsessed with that you think how is this
ever going away but they could be a
thing of the past someday oh god well i
mean i think definitely growing up i
consumed lots of like vegetable oil
based products
and uh
i remember i would think that like
plant-based was was generally better for
you
i was never vegan or plant-based or
anything like that but i remember like i
would swap out a few meals here and
there like a few animal products with
like you know occasionally like a soy
product you know i remember
uh discovering soyrizo and like using
that and yeah it's like a chorizo but
it's like made of like soy it's loaded
with soy nuggets and
yeah it's like the most processed
garbage like like ever i think i would
buy it from like trader joe's but it's
like
really delicious actually when you put
eggs you know
of course it's delicious it's like ultra
it's like engineered it's totally
engineered yeah yeah and um and so i
would eat that i would i remember i
would like drink soy milk instead of
like regular milk i still occasionally
enjoy like almond milk and like i had a
macadamia nut milk like matcha latte
earlier but um but soy milk i remember i
would drink all the time um and i would
just get so bloated from it like after
just like a cup of it i would like i
wouldn't understand like why right
i'm so healthy i'm just going to keep
doing it
yeah
right we get we get something in our
head yeah i would feel like [ __ ]
but um
but you know i would just like i thought
that it was like healthier right it had
almost as much protein as a cup of milk
but it wasn't milk so
how bad could it be right and so i yeah
i would eat all that stuff i would i
would buy like
fake butter products
totally oh i would also
use i was a big user for a while of
flaxseed oil
as my
omega-3 source which i know now is a
really bad really a really poor source
of omega-3 fatty acids
because they don't easily get converted
in the body especially the male body to
dha and epa which are their active forms
in the body yeah so
now i take fish oil when i want butter i
use like real butter
um
i've been drinking like i've got like
goat milk in my fridge i'm like a
different different person these days
yeah i love goat cheese yeah it's
awesome it's actually i mean goat milk
goat dairy is a good source of medium
chain triglycerides
too you don't even have to you get like
the nutrients of goat cheese and goat
milk right like protein but it's not
and mcts but it's not empty calories
like mct oil
yeah i'd rather use goat dairy products
than
mct oil which is again just like empty
calories
you've just changed my mind i'm gonna
get i'm gonna be putting that goat milk
in now nice it's good it's like kind of
sweet
so
goat products
what else are you doing right now that
you're
so convinced on
uh
[Music]
what about like some other modalities
like a cotton cold sauna ice cold plunge
yeah
any of that stuff i do all that but i
feel like people like people are already
familiar with that you know but i love
sauna i'm a huge sauna fan for what it
does to my cardiovascular system
my brain health
sweating out toxins you know which we
know we accumulate
um
super important um i wrote in my second
book about endocrine disrupting
compounds and just how we're like
they're just ever present in our
environments totally um
and
because of the food industrial complex
you know our vegetables now are a source
of like of heavy metals and stuff and so
when you when you sweat you legitimately
excrete
compounds that
don't um effectively get excreted to
other ways you know like
urine for example like you actually
sweat out various toxins so i think it's
important to sweat regularly do you take
binders as well
no i don't i've uh i've heard of those
but i'm not i haven't like looked into
them well i had
i'm cleaning up heavy metal toxicity
like i had some seriously high mercury
like the threshold is five and mine was
170.
wow last summer when i did a provoked
urine test so
um
but yeah binding is just charcoal clay
fulvic acid those kinds of things
because
essentially yeah you sweat some of it
out but you liberate a lot of it and
especially if you you know if it stays
in the body and it's liberated it can go
somewhere else or like more can go up to
the brain
so
binding with the heat and
the sort of detoxing can be
just a smart thing to do i guess yeah i
want to learn more about that for sure i
mean i yeah i generally just i'll sweat
um
i think i think like that's that's super
important whether or not you have access
to a sauna like i think it's one of the
major reasons why exercise is so
beneficial oh yeah um
and i'm not like a big sweater when i
exercise like especially with like with
weights i don't really i tend not to
sweat very often but i've been
trying to do a little bit more cardio
these days which
uh for a long time i neglected and now
i'm
you know i think i'm starting to
come back around to the benefits like
the whole body benefits of cardio of
cardio exercise i'm trying to do a
little bit more of that these days so
what's your split like how many lifting
how many cardio sessions a week
well i think with any exercise program
first of all whatever you like to do
like just just keep doing that but also
i do think that it's important to to do
both and to not set the bar too high so
as to not
be able to adopt a sustainable routine
so for me
like
what i started with was
you know i'm just gonna try to run a
mile a day like that's not if you think
about it like that's an eight or nine
minute commitment you know
or ten minute commitment it's really not
it's really not that difficult to do
yeah um i mean even even for somebody
who's like not trained you're still have
to work your way up to that i suppose
but um
but you know rather than try to push it
like every day like oh i did a mile now
i'm gonna do two miles i'm gonna do
three miles
i just know how my brain works and if i
got to a point where i was doing four
miles at a certain at some point i'd be
like oh i don't really you know [ __ ] i
don't really feel like doing four miles
today you know true it becomes too big
of a hurdle you have to certainly have a
hurdle yeah yeah you have to make it
accessible
accessible yeah and and like something
that you can like do
again and again and again so for me
it's like if i could just do a mile
that's it that's like all i'm that's
better than nothing right so
and i don't really love running like i
like it now because i've gotten my
cardiovascular like my aerobic base to a
point where like it's actually fairly
easy for me to do a mile now but um but
yeah i don't i don't really try to push
it like every day i just try to make
sure that i'm doing a mile
yeah and um and i feel really good about
about that you know that's a great
lesson make it accessible keep it so
that it's within reach because
otherwise it'll be discouraging i love
that yeah just a mile and like it might
take you 10 or 11 minutes at first but
like eventually you'll be able to as you
get more used to it you know also i
think what's key is like good good
running shoes
so get yourself a pair of those but yeah
just like try to do a mile try to do a
mile a day like if you do a mile a day i
do a treadmill i like running on a
treadmill more than i like running
outside
so um but yeah i've been doing it
most days most days and it's great some
days if i feel really energetic and i'm
at the mile i'm like okay i could i
could i'm feeling good why stop now i'll
do a mile and a half but the next day
i again go back to let's just see if we
can do a model
you know it's not it's not like i build
these like impossible or like these ever
it's not like you know the expectation
that i have of myself increases with
every workout
i'm just like
as long as i can do a mile it's better
than not doing a model i think that's a
like i feel like that's a very holistic
approach for you in general like that
feels like how you're talking about food
and
you know how that shows up in your life
and what you do is just make things
accessible like do a good job most of
the time
yeah
longevity
longevity it's it's don't stress about
it don't stress about it yeah because
it's like you know one single meal is
not going to sway your health in any
direction right either to
in a negative way or a positive way it's
about the pattern it's about the dietary
patterns about what you do how you eat
day in and day out and the same thing
goes for your exercise
yeah so
i know that i love i've always loved
weightlifting like that's my default
like i go into a gym and i'm like at
home in a gym you know with with that
but the cardio thing has always been
like
a hurdle for me because i just feel like
you know i'm tall like my my body is
like i was never an athlete really so
running for me is not something that i
just like really enjoy but i think it's
so important i think it's like important
for your
um
just for everything for your brain for
your
you know for your coordination for your
mobility for your joints
well thank you i think you've shared so
many great gems and helped me learn
about so many various different things
screw that mct oil i interviewed dave
tomorrow so i'm going to tell him that
dave asprey yeah
oh man he i mean whenever i post about
kale he
he's the first to comment of course oh
and i recently started talking about why
like i think butter is like a super
tasty great food to use in moderation
but it's not something that i like
regularly
consuming you saw that yeah so i made a
different choice today by the way i put
cream in raw dairy raw cream i love that
like well max said that butter's not all
that in the
cherry on top so i'll just put the cream
in yeah i love that but you know it's
like uh i feel like dave probably isn't
gonna want to hear that but um but you
know
i'm not dogmatic and i also am not uh
i'm non-combative with people that have
differing and opposing viewpoints than
my own right like i think that
i think that the whole of of humanity
benefits from the plurality of voices as
opposed to
any one single entity controlling the
conversation
and um and me you know like when i got
started
it was books it was like it was like
you know
like the the the functional medicine
doctors that really were
uh offered hope to me and you know i
learned that everybody has like a
different viewpoint and at the end of
the day it compelled me to
dive into like the medical literature
for myself to to to
develop my own sort of internal
truth compass right but
i think the more voices we can have in
the space the better and they don't have
to be md's they don't have to be phds
they i think like you know a highly
motivated generalist amateur
um oftentimes can have more to offer
than you know than phds who are so mired
in their little microcosms you know or
md's who are trained in accordance to
like practice guideline-based medicine
which is influenced by so many variables
not least of which money right
open up the focus right instead of being
an expert in one little area
it's about more being a generalist and i
think that invokes this sort of like
real sort of chill approach that you
have to it so i appreciate that i'm sure
that's why so many people follow you and
love your stuff so thank you
thank you so much this was so fun
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button